did you hear that Canada has they're
banning whale and dolphin captivity I
think it's great I think it's great too
they apparently just passed I mean how
about blackfish one documentary and it
like kind of I think initiated a
movement oh for sure yeah people didn't
know they needed to just see it in a
digestible form instead of having to go
seek it out and read articles about it
and news reports instead of that they
get to see it there it is in a very
digestible formula oh my god this is
chaos this is horrible this is an
atrocity you're taking these incredible
animals that are probably some of the
most magnificent creatures that
evolution has ever created and you're
putting them in a fish tank you're
putting them in a swimming pool yeah
there's their fins go yeah that's crazy
well actually if you think about the
killer whale I mean that's the king yeah
just a crazy video that I just watched
yesterday of one killing a beach seal
and it injured the seal and the seal
tried to make it over into and it
literally beached itself smash this seal
and those just blood everywhere and
these bunch of people are standing
around watching it going holy shit yeah
and then it flopped its way back into
the water and swam off it did it yeah
okay go well that's what I mean listen
that's the thing about nature right it's
it's it's kind of brutal but it's not
personal like the see the you know
there's whales not like you know that
seal gave me kind of a funny look right
I'm gonna go and give it to him it's
like oh there's some food did you ever
see the one when they're on the iceberg
and they look oh that bugger still
holding on and then push it again I mean
I was teaching its calves at a hunt to
mark that she was setting it up but
showing like you can make him slide like
watch this well slide well I was
listening to my friend Stephen Ellis
podcast and he was talking about the
difference in the orcas in the Puget
Sound and that their local orcas which
are essentially salmon specialists yeah
and they don't eat animals they don't
eat marine mammals but then there are
other ones that travel into the area and
they are marine mammal specialists so
they all they eat is like seals and and
and things along those lines and they
have a totally different language
totally don't understand each other they
don't interact with each other
is that every pod has its own language
it's crazy they they put a whale in
captivity once and it was not eating
because they didn't know it was a seal
eating whale not a fish eating well and
so it learned I used to joke can you
imagine like okay Susie and Billy we're
gonna go watch the you know the Orca
Shamu and then the trainer's they're
like throwing it seal like that would
not work out well like yay that trick
again yeah give it a slab of cute little
animal ya know so it's a they're very
complex yeah